bonjour à tous nos éditeurs vous êtes
bien sûr jamais la radio
aujourd'hui nous allons nous intéresser
à l esclavage et plus précisément à son
abolition
malena et la présentatrice du jour avec
ses chroniqueurs
elle parle de l' esclavage d'hier et
d'aujourd'hui pour la webradio du lycée
jean vilar de plaisir s'est présenté
vers l'introduction présenter toutes les
personnes qui vont parler c'est faire
les transitions conclure poser des
questions à chaque personne chaque
groupe et chaque oeil ce sujet la
présentatrice en herbe fait partie des
29 élèves de cette classe de seconde qui
travaille sur la web radio depuis un
trimestre oui c'est ce trait semble
stressant mais on s'habitue et une fois
qu'on est on parle tout tout tout se
passe bien ce projet de radio 100%
lycéenne s'inscrit dans le cadre de
l'éducation aux médias et à
l'information
les jeunes sont sensibilisés à la
réalisation d'un travail de groupe
le format de la radio c'est intéressant
parce que ça permet de travailler
plusieurs compétences en amont la
recherche documentaire donc c'est pour
ça qu'on travaille au cdi ça demande
aussi un travail d'écriture d'expression
écrite puisque avant d'être dit le texte
est écrit
donc aussi une rave on travaille sur la
correction de la langue classe aussi le
moyen de faire travailler un
d'expression orale tous les élèves
puisque tous les élèves passent devant
le micro
lancée en 2016 par une professeure de
sciences économiques et sociales elle
est disponible en podcast sur le site du
lycée jean vilar